three
two
one zero ignition blasting off from
nasa's kennedy space center in cape
canaveral florida spacex's falcon 9
rocket launches for a journey to the
international space station
live view inside the cabin onboarder
businessman larry connor mark pathy and
eaton stibb each paid 55 million dollars
for their ticket
leading the crew for the 20-hour flight
is retired nasa astronaut michael lopez
alegria it's the first civilian
astronaut team to travel to the iss
nasa and others say it's a milestone in
the commercialization of low earth orbit
the significance is this flight is
something that nasa
and spacex and its other commercial
partners have been working towards you
know where they are able to take
commercial industry and put it into
space and so this is um the first
step into a broader
world for that so it's very exciting
the mission is a collaboration between
elon musk spacex commercial space flight
company axiom and nasa spacex directed
mission control for the flight from the
company's headquarters near los angeles
spectators who watched the launch said
they wanted to see history being made at
my age i don't think there's much chance
i'll be back in america to see another
one so today was the day when i wanted
to see the launch go up i wanted to see
a manned
space launch go away there's so much to
explore there's so much unknown you know
i mean we talk about our world and you
know what we haven't yet found you're
bottom of the oceans yeah the top of the
mountains and space is infinite you know
out there is unknown
the team is set to arrive at the
international space station on saturday
and despite being tourists they'll spend
eight days conducting scientific
research stage one landing light
deployed victoria gatenbee al jazeera